[Music]
it's an ode to the way that things used
to be made it's not just something
that's been mass-produced or put through
a line and made millions of we make them
hand by hand individually each one
there's definitely faster ways there's
ways to cut corners but how do we make
something without cutting any corners
what's the best way we can do it it's a
long way to do it it's a hard way to do
it but if there's a way to do it that
way then we figure it out you can really
see that in the quality of the bags when
you get one when you hold one my name is
Lindy McDonough and I'm the creative
director at load of leather for us you
know we grew up in New England and I
would get a bag one season and have a
big logo on it and then two seasons
later you'd almost be embarrassed to
have it and you know that's not in New
England how we grow up how we have Goods
you know you should have a thing that
you can pass down to your next to your
next generation train wrecks that's
gonna get more beautiful as you use it
and that was always the ethos for the
company the triumph briefcase from the
outside it looks very clean but it's
actually a very complicated about its
one of the most difficult bags that we
make takes about four to six weeks to
make each one there's no rush in that
the bag has about 61 individual pieces
in each bag we start on the cutting
table we roll out a hide our hides all
come from a family-owned tannery our
leather is all made specially for us all
of the leather is fully vegetable tanned
so no chromium no formaldehyde nothing
in the base if you've ever had a piece
of leather goods that over time starts
to peel and there's white that's showing
through that means that there's actually
some sort of chemical or chromium inside
the leather that's causing it to rust
our leather won't do that it'll get more
beautiful in patina as you use it
you're also looking for you know
imperfections in the heights Oh tick
bites scars open cuts anything like that
just making sure at the beginning
process that you find it make sure we
don't use it the bags then go through
and all 61 of those pieces are cut from
one hide you're actually getting someone
who laid out that cut and then thought
about what was the piece that's going
next to it and I thought about the piece
that was going next to that they all get
cut and individually numbered and then
we'll bring them over to the splitter
splitting is taking the leather and
making it thinner we have different
weights for every part of the bag from
the design process to it's one of those
things that we spend a lot of time
thinking about like could this be a
little bit thinner could this be thicker
we measure every single piece and we
measure it to actually the tenth of an
ounce we really do pay a lot of
attention to the weight of every piece
once everything is split it goes to the
grinding station the grinding station is
where all of the pieces are shaped we
take all of the pieces and we stand them
straight all of those pieces are shaped
and ground and done by an eye
it's one of those things of why what we
do can't be automated
from the grinding station it moves to
the painting station we have about four
people painting to every one person at
every other station because we do fully
traditional burnish and polished edges
the painters get the ground pieces they
paint a lair and they essentially raise
the grain of the leather and then they
bring it over to the buffing machine and
then buff it and then they bring it back
to the painting station and then they
paint another coat of edge dye and then
they would buff it again and you're
going back and forth with all 61 of
those pieces at the minimum of three
times and some of which eight that's why
we hire artists they have an eye for it
and they're like this is not right yet
and they will finish it until it's right
so when we started this space this
manufacturing stays five years ago we
had three people and now we are at 22
it's pretty rough our team at load up is
75% women 75% of them are under the age
of 35 and about 70% of them have a
bachelor's degree always the biggest
struggle has been how do you find work
that you know you have a day job from
nine to five that can support your life
as an artist and that was always the
vision behind what we do for load if you
have furniture makers jewelry designers
print makers illustrators painters and
so making a great job they could come in
work with us 30 hours a week get full
benefits health care all of those
benefits and then getting to do their
studio practice outside of it is a
really amazing thing and we get amazing
work because of that and I think it's
what makes what goes into the bag so
special
in between the painting phase and the
stitching phase there's one piece in
every bag that gets the bag number and
the load of logo and so those pieces
come to the monogramming station we log
all of the numbers in our records we
know what pieces were going through what
color it was what style it was and what
number is correlated to that then things
go to stitching so all 61 of those
pieces for the trampled and brought over
and get the first level of stitching we
use a super strong thread that's made by
a local maker we get all the thread dyed
to match each one of the leather colors
for the most part every single one of
the pieces has a specific amount of
stitches that's their stitch width from
the edge is really specific the amount
of stitches per inch is really specific
all of that is considered and then they
get moved to the turnin burn station
which is our hand stitching station so
they've finished the thread with a hand
tied not burn it and then tuck it back
into the same hole where it came from so
it will actually hold and then close the
leather over it so it's locking
essentially that stitch inside of the
leather the hand stitching element is
something that makes our bags pretty
special after it's turn and burn we'll
go back to painting and buffing and then
it would all go to assembly assembly
station is where they're gluing and
assembling the bags from the
two-dimensional pieces into the
three-dimensional and there's different
levels of that
they will take all of the gussets and
all the partitions glue them and then
they hammer it there's kind of a lot of
back and forth between those stations
until it's done
it goes back to grinding and then back
to painting and then just the full loop
all the way again it does that about
five times before the bag is finished
the very last thing that we do is
monogramming the bags and then we
handwrite note and then there's a card
that goes in every bag that has the bag
number let's put in a beautiful gift box
that's the last step before the bag is
shipped up it's important that
everything's made here it's about
accountability its accountability to our
customers it's making sure that we are
doing things the way that we say that
we're doing it and watching every step
of the way and we really couldn't do
that if we weren't making it here and
making it ourselves and we can really
say that we look at every single piece
and make sure that it's perfect before
it goes out the door we're not just a
marketing company but we're actually
we're a maker company
[Music]
you